dude wouldn't you push yourself when you
set your goals right yeah I quit you
gotta remember no hey you can't that's
see that and the problem is you don't
have energy see how your energy is right
now just so low dude I know and a little
hungover a little gay yeah cuz you're
not optimized as marked Norman with know
your name I blame but mark marks
optimized and I'm not dude you need to
get you need it not move I need to look
your world you want a new mood and I got
a new mood
I got melatonin spray so you sleep
better I got alpha brain so you think
better and you focus in your memories
better I got stuff that supports your
vitality y'all I got that big around
almond milk latte MCT I'll squirt it
directly in your mouth or [ __ ] I
didn't know yeah dude you're
recommending it for your bunghole too
you never know the bad guys the bottom
line is this is the thing about on it it
is the best supplement line money can
buy go name one that's sticking around
these days what I always suck it's when
I say on it these supplement companies
who come and go promise a whole bunch of
stuff but I'll tell you what the one
promise on it two things on it their
owners take their products every day we
get me be a co-sponsor this HOH what is
that this is a train that don't stop and
you need to treat that [ __ ] you body's
a machine it needs the kind of fuel that
keeps on or.com slash fighter tempers
off the whole damn website calm slash
fighter support and vitality and
performance they got it all for you on
ted.com slash fighter Brandon talk to me
about whoop you want me to whoop it up
look I wouldn't have the thing bro
yesterday went on a hike yeah I'm using
this app on my phone tells me like the
this how far I'm going right it says six
mile hike
yeah I've thrown that whoop I throw on
that whoopty whoop because left on that
whoop yeah it was actually seven a half
miles so it's in a lot of ways the most
accurate wristband hold on it's the only
wristband you should have rockin because
it monitors your heart rate 24/7 over a
hundred times a second so you know they
do it better than all the other way
better there's nothing like it there's
nothing like it also if you're working
out like crazy you know what's more
important than your workouts recovery
yeah yup
so damn important how hard you strain it
they're gonna tell you they let me know
exactly on my hikes when I'm working out
at home how does it teach you actually
that you're getting like REM sleep sleep
sleep sleep because like all that till
the highest-level loop provides insights
that others just don't not this level
not at this precise level you can tell
if you have sleep apnea if you're waking
up all the time your heart rate
everything maybe not feeling well maybe
you shouldn't do that seven mile hike
today because you're not fully recovered
maybe didn't get the sleep you thought
maybe save for the next day yeah when
you're whoop tells you you ready to go
dancing huge part of not getting I'm
tight so it's a game changer it's a life
changer the battery lasts for a day they
get their new 3.0 strapped you guys get
$30 off that's right you get $30 off go
to whoop calm that's whio peace calm use
the code fighter at checkout to save $30
and optimize the way you train fighter
for 30th fighter for $30 off whoop
membership get you some Hey Gillis
he's guy got fired for making that [ __ ]
joke yeah he's a good guy good no I'm
just kidding not anymore
people got people a lot of Asians it
reached out to me and I don't know about
you but oh yeah kind of defending him in
there like hey [ __ ]
you know I've been dealing with this
[ __ ] you know they're very sensitive
somewhere like yeah their main thing
you'll replace what he said about
Chinese about black people here at
n-word yeah still defend them
I want absolutely not yeah I'm not you
know I get it this consequences and
whatever and that's no can do whatever
the hell they want but it's like I was
trying to be funny yeah even if it
wasn't he's not it's in the Comedy
category and they're clumsy miss it was
a bad miss but everybody goes can you
believe that then they spine [ __ ] on
them when you go what about this ten
years ago and you said this [ __ ] joke
or whatever and they go well that that
was a different time I've evolved and
like well let him evolve and when you
typed it were you full of hate
no well leave
maybe isn't either then like did you see
the guy he is fine
no horse did you see the guy who I think
Anna's your Bush or some he's like the
bear guy has like a million followers
have you seen this no the canceled
culture so he did some tweet like years
ago so first of all this guy made his
craft mean like this bear guy and he
would take the proceeds and he donated a
million dollars like over a million
dollars to a hospital so he's a good
dude Wow I don't know exactly I got
fired from but they dropped them and the
the the publishing company the outlet
that published him saying all these bad
things the guy who did it they went well
let's see what you didn't I guess he had
of course add tweets so I'm not firing
him we all just like how deep do you
want to go we all say or think yeah it's
pirate right anyway up there uh let me
see Chen scroll out Alta dealt it hey
cyclone nation I just wanted everyone to
know I'm listening to cyclone Facebook
from New York City which we are set over
at a 7,000 yeah that's him like that's
the first tweet but that's not what got
him in trouble is it I don't know you
have fired for something and if you got
a post all this high school users tweets
from his from his high school blackface
everything about dude I was gonna say I
was gonna start with a fantastic half
Kalin ask me how I'm doing go a little
hungover a little gay oh yeah that dude
who said that he did I was it was that
in is that Portland
oh please that's right oh hey cuz I knew
he was a comic and then I was getting
ready to do press and I always like to
look into it and like oh yeah look up
mark look it up look out like what and I
can't look it up so I look it up and
doun have you showed you that thanks
that's poor girl I actually rolled with
it she was a pro I was really impressed
but it's one things we do four of those
in a day in Herodium you're hungover you
hate yourself you're gay and you're just
like I'm gonna be myself [ __ ] I can't
keep it in anymore I can't do the shuck
and jive and that's the funny stuff and
the weird thing is I've done a million
of those but for some reason that one
just got put on YouTube
I think of so much of this is just you
were just being honest with how you felt
yeah and all of this [ __ ] if the data
ultimately is gonna win we laugh when
you're honest what's legs well he
doesn't work we're like beautiful town
and I'm just here yeah yeah oh that's
not so many tick right and rather this
thing about comedy I [ __ ] that that
is it's the last place where all of us
misfits can get together and [ __ ]
just speak our minds yeah and because I
swear to god I'm starting to hang out at
the comedy store I've been doing a lot
of sets lately and it reminds me of all
I'm getting to know some of the younger
comics they're all [ __ ] misfits of
course they're all they're all awesome
and they're also their own worst enemy
in with what Brendan and I had this idea
we well we're trying to get companies to
give us an idea that they want a
marketing idea and then Brenda and I are
gonna put comics together sit around a
roundtable to come up with a great ways
to sell their product yeah oh the funny
way to do it like young hungry comics
we'd have the idea so Brett hey them
okay and we have real money for that and
so Brenda and I said let's do a contest
we'll just like pair off we go hey guys
here's the idea just come up with a
one-minute video and I reached out there
like 10 comics not [ __ ] Noah and a111
sent a video yeah no show bad doing this
I love Mike Mike's funny as [ __ ] but
Michael anoche
it's [ __ ] is the only guy who submits
something will bud and I was like hey
dude hey Mike and Mike's funny Mike's a
good comic I was like hey Mike
this sucks what are you doing I got
money for you everybody else blew it off
at least Mike showed up everybody else
know their debt to Rogen about it and he
was like oh yeah oh yeah comics are
complete misfits they're supposed to be
look hug garbage you and I mean look at
noir McDonald on the funniest guys on
the planet he can't drive and he's a
gambling exactly you know he's lost all
his money I feel better it's good
exactly so then it almost is a weird
it's this weird dysfunction yeah is is
goes part and parcel almost across the
board be learned like the people have
been saying you know he's been in LA for
a few days around the Comedy Store and
improv you but they said No
he's the new countin oh what's that yeah
I said you're kind of out older what
just sayin dude mark step up for me you
saw me destroy last night or maybe you
didn't I missed it sorry
hey who I met speaking of beautiful
misfits Sam Tripoli Susan want you to
meet my friend Jennifer and I said hi
Jennifer beautiful beautiful tall skank
and a nice no it's all that's all was a
real piece no not tall this this is this
was where you were the dope so you
walking with a real tree oh no two trees
no yeah they're not skanks oh those
girls are one girl's a pro athlete oh I
don't think it's a bit good trim some
nice skirts
yeah real dame the hatchet wound yeah
love hole runnin low on Thank You Marc
oh sorry so ya know the I I don't know
who you're referring to but I do
remember the very very tall woman
brunette - - been very pretty yeah yeah
yeah okay undermine what about this
Jennifer but but so I meet I I can all
stage and I'm kind of and he says I want
you to meet you know my friend and her
name is Jennifer Lopez nope and I and I
went and she was in a beautiful kind of
like just a classy dress and she was
good gorgeous and I was like there's
something about it - that's just kind of
like magnetic and okay how are you and
please tell me she was pretty
her name was Jennifer white I guess Sam
tripley's favorite porn star whoa
Jennifer white Jennifer why she's no
porn is something else
a porno viewer and there with her
husband was John and uh she's with her
husband yeah
I'm familiar with gorge I've seen it
work Holly I have not seen her well I've
never work in cheese I have not she
knows her way around a she's got okay
she is look at the hi he's quite a
caboose the kid cool and they're cool
like just funny joking around later like
you never know I was like how are you a
porn star you're so how can you know I
can't relax around porn star because
it's nobody's actual energy why do you
feel like should we [ __ ] now exactly
what you do why is my dick dry geez why
is my picture Wednesday yeah here's the
thing dude yeah it's like it's like if
she hung out with you and you were lame
like you're a comic so right expecting
to be funny right yeah I'm expecting the
bus she turns it off she's first of all
she was 31 so which way that has me gone
over the hill okay no that's what I like
she's 31
and also so she's right she's not
working she's there to watch a [ __ ]
comedy show right her ass off with I
think her husband or her friends so
she's a civilian
right she when you meet her she's a
civilian [ __ ] you want to pay her a lot
of money a lot oh look go ahead but get
the [ __ ] out of here otherwise tonight
this is that's what she does it's almost
like it's almost like a fighter going
man this guy's a tough guy but he was so
nice to me well yeah he's not getting
paid to be right [ __ ] he's not me I'll
take your head off exactly oh she's
delicious very good hard in the pain huh
I like her alright hey hey hey you had a
ten on you just said he doesn't it's
Gaddy doesn't watch porn why it seemed a
little pent up I never watch porn Wow
and I haven't watched porn in maybe over
here done yeah do it every day and it's
got to be black I don't know how do you
do it you what are you imagination like
eighth grade style I I'm older I just I
don't know yeah I don't think back to I
don't even turned off in black-and-white
I swear to God what I'm just get the
[ __ ] out you're sitting you're weird
that's really I manage he's better than
ya now cuz my dad looked at my history
about it was probably six years ago and
he looked at my I was traveling at the
house and he looks at my [ __ ]
computer and he goes what is this yeah
he put in something and he goes what is
this porn porn black guy so I go oh I
watched porn yeah I think Jesus are you
single mark no I got a hot hot lady at
home oh really oh yeah and now do you do
announce it out there on on Instagram
and stuff yeah anything get in trouble
if you don't ya know I don't care like
to me I just want to like plug gigs and
she's like you gotta show people and I'm
like alright alright so annoying I just
I don't want to do social media I just
do it to get seats you know yeah I wish
I didn't have to
it's brutal brutal I got some friends
who don't do it and they're so much
happier they're just later they sell
tickets sell do like Nate bargatze pays
a lady to do all that [ __ ] I don't wanna
do that my whole life change with that
special of course which is rare now he's
gonna come on the podcast he's great but
there's a few guys who don't do
socialite I have cat run most of it my
brother and then I'll definitely check
in but it is it's so toxic man yeah yeah
and just the effort that you put into it
wait so you're seeing his DMS oh yeah
hopefully not all yeah cuz never you're
a hot hunk of meat there sir
Oh Shabba shop yeah look at that thigh
alone could feed a family so ladies the
ladies like nowhere tell us about your
thicky
they call him a thick e I must I was
sitting with these girls sitting with I
was sitting this girl kept going 3z he's
a picky and say he's so cute yeah they
like good hair line good car great to
you yeah and you're always trying to
lose weight don't lose it just be big
you're thick crust there should be went
the name of my new Taurus thick crust
yeah
deep dish I just like thick crust with
Reese's you uh how about this how about
Seinfeld said you're his favorite
comedian I feel weird that's awesome no
I was a [ __ ] myself he's like I don't
mean to interrupt you but he's like so
critical of comedy and Laura's been
going on he's my hero or one I mean I
watched him the show with my parents you
know like it's crazy he's such a big
part of my comedy life that sitcom and
like curb and his his a documentary
comedian was huge so like just things
idea that you could you could life can
be long enough to meet him is insane
guys have any interaction yeah we hung
out that night for like an hour and a
half and like got exchanged numbers now
we text every now and then say just
seeing that name it's like a porn star
or like a supermodel like oh I'm like
smell checking and let me delete that
and rewrite you know right exactly just
to send him video send it to your
parents like [ __ ] you dad my parents
don't care about anything that's the one
thing that they were like that's pretty
good yeah give me that one that means
you're doing something right yeah yeah
exactly that and also I wonder like if
he heard my whole act cuz he saw me do a
corporate gig and I to be clean huh and
I killed but if he saw my real act I
think he would [ __ ] blood you know it's
just you know school shootings
pedophilia like I like the dark stuff
you know much like cat where'd you grow
new orleans yeah she's a dirty bird you
got the vibe but yeah New Orleans
Louisiana go Saints go st. you see it's
a kind of [ __ ] yeah they're always
[ __ ] although we're easy the Seahawks
which was shocking it's true man but
yeah yeah I got fun place to grow up
it's it's a weird place for a kid I lost
my virginity to a prostitute you know
tough Davidoff oh yeah you really do
really I like you likes me so much of
yeah interesting huh how do you figure
he's a junkyard guy right he was quite a
swinger in his day if I might say
like your swing yeah I I've had some
I've had some time oh you did the row
with him for a while over close when I
dove and I did it right
wow that's quite a threesome I would say
you're gonna gal in the middle of that
sandwich and by the way he's working
with a field mask oh is he yeah he's got
a piece on him
oh that's intimidating nope nope not for
me but I know you man
by the way never forget who the who
daddy is I mean at the end of the day I
was older the bottom line is that dove 1
alpha dove is a special dude and has the
darkness and has all the you remind he's
doing comedy is he's back in right he's
in he's in New York you see oh yeah all
the time yes hilarious and he's got his
own thing he sounds very no one sounds
like duh yeah jasmine yes he is jesse is
he's got a little jazz and surly eyes
who are just so they're onto such a
different frequency like dove like fie
oh yeah I'm just I'm never gonna hear
this anywhere else there's a good common
good comparison to cuz just so it's like
a unique sound it's like when the casket
are right two places right you know it's
the air yeah the same like some people
have that [ __ ] that yeah that just a
doozy yeah yeah it's a different vibe
one hasn't heard it before and the weird
thing about that is starting out with a
different fruit like jazel neck you
really struggle starting always be like
what is this [ __ ] but you know give it a
second [ __ ] it's gonna get into
separate you just gotta go with me trust
me you know that's why I hate the
industry they can't see that then when
they the person figures it out and they
get good in Chicago we love you we
always a big fan up Nick is a big fan
big fan isn't the best he's proof that
you can say whatever you want be dark as
long as it's a bit no one gives a [ __ ]
God he is dark to men never killed
anyone then I remembered Jennifer he
really is yeah my he's like can I buy a
motorcycle his mom's like no your
brother died on a motorcycle so don't
buy you can just have his brilliant
jokes yeah I am he's almost that way
backstage too it's not like he's running
here backstage
there but he's not that warm he's always
standoffish you know that's your really
cool to meet a nice guy you know he was
really nice to me and then I went yeah I
went on first and then then I brought
him out and then he just roast like we
don't know each other that well and
roasted the [ __ ] I don't know like my
feelings are sober I'm like what the
[ __ ] man I didn't but this was bright
two or three years ago and I didn't
realize what kind of comic you was yeah
and then I wouldn't win the back like
jeez man [ __ ] Jeselnik and like oh
that's what he does do yeah yeah I'm
like really like yeah of course that's
his thing yeah yeah I got in trouble
less and I don't want to say her name
but there was a large black woman I went
on and I had to follow her and I said
give it up for Ron Funches you know and
the place went nuts but she went she was
not into it just just to get a laugh out
of the game yes nothing it's you I like
you am wrong but I thought was a perfect
line yeah you could [ __ ] on me all day
you know I get robot and you know weirdo
autism you know go nuts you're a [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] breath of fresh air in
this in this politically correct
brain-dead Los Angeles environment well
I got to tell you you guys are more free
and fun than New York right now yeah
we're talking about before we came in oh
are you kidding these your line up
psycho we're gonna get in trouble
there's no Asian on it you know and then
it's the Santino's like I relax it's LA
New York they're kind of imposing oh
it's it's coming in hard and like look
I'm all about diversity and I get it and
blah blah blah but like I'm not what
happened comedy I'm not whoa funny what
I mean is are you funny enough to be in
a lineup sure a nice young ticket [ __ ]
you I don't give a [ __ ] if you're black
white I don't get I don't how many was
at one place that was so so kidding
about whether you had a limp whether you
were blue yeah we're trans I don't give
a [ __ ] what you are if you're funny if
you think you can get into a lineup with
the kind of comment it's going on at the
Comedy Store then then none of us care
yeah I completely agree
we've never cared actually if you were
gay if you if you like having [ __ ]
spit in your mouth I I mean not to lean
for me well we I know
comics who we all would it's it's the
land of the misfits yeah of course and
sorry about using the expression tran
[ __ ] I guess transsexual son of a
[ __ ] but you know I'm saying is like
totally no you see the comedy was in one
place where it didn't matter if you had
three dicks it didn't matter what you
were are you funny enough three dicks is
a great Neal Brennan yeah it just sucks
because when I was it's so pushed down
your throat now that I can't relax like
when I was a kid I liked Ellen I liked
Paula Poundstone but I wasn't like I
like these female comedians but now you
push it in me more that I go oh I like
that Michelle wolf I'm a big fan because
she's a woman and I love women and the
yeah it's made me actually less
progressive my ass let's turn on exactly
yeah I don't think of Whitney Cummings
or Eliza here who are friends of mine I
know when they're on a live I'm not
going oh we got some women there I'm
just thinking this is gonna be a Crayola
yeah exactly yes that's right stop for
it the more you force the more we go hey
you push back if you just let it happen
it'll happen none of us would give a
[ __ ] in a transsexual whoever or
somebody who identified as a a bird was
what was in the lineup if you're funny
all right dragging with you backstage
like UFC no one's going we got to get
Silva in he's a black guy no he's just
good can you punch it in the face
exactly it's all very simple you've been
doing County for how long yeah I'm at 12
13 ish so you're 35 so you started a
little late right 22 23 no I mean that's
not too bad you didn't start in like did
you I do in high school now I just had
such a low self-esteem that it was like
it was being it was like Carlin Cosby
like I was like I could never do that so
that's how I looked at it and then one
day I just got drunk enough and trying
to open mic and how old were you then I
was 22 and in where did you do the open
mic it it was in Lafayette Louisiana
because I was so scared of someone
seeing me in New Orleans and I drove
three hours to do the five minute open
mic and I just had a bunch of cocktails
and went on and it went pretty well
and then where'd you go from there then
I said I want to do this I love it and I
moved to New York and bomb for three
years straight and got mugged three
times at a year landlord died of AIDS
and I got bedbugs
all in one year yeah Wow I probably
should have closed on the AIDS
yeah yeah it was a hellish hellish
transition you know that's like Jenner
but it was tough man but now I just kept
at it and I had nothing else to turn to
I had mean I was against the cliff my
back was against the wall so I just kept
going so when you first got to New York
you're just doing open mics or were you
yeah then how when did you start getting
spots at like the legit places four or
five years in I mean it takes forever I
mean you got a little bar show here and
there but nothing where you're like
paying the rent now when you're on it
takes so long uh yeah just one thing
where you tell me about this b2 went
because Brian star in New York is you're
able to do like eight sets nine yes
tonight I think with Steve Byrne did
like 17 or some [ __ ] like that he did a
documentary about it but yeah I would do
I mean I was [ __ ] in my 20s yeah 30
student I would do one summer I was
doing literally I remember I would start
at 8:00 and I'd be done by 1:00 see
exactly I was going to every [ __ ]
Club you would just just get it in yeah
do I don't know and then I do open mics
her there'd be some [ __ ] thing at the
rebar where it was and you do you'd end
up doing fibers I feel like if I get
four sets in LA it's a night but then I
think about you guys I'm like well for
LA fourth good sports good friend don't
get you sets a good point where it's a
good fourth a lot five five you start
repeating yourself it isn't yeah [ __ ]
about you don't want to get too crazy
about this [ __ ] okay we were it I did
those sets because I had nothing else to
do and I was just happy to do him and I
had nothing else in my life
right same so much of you talked about
low self-esteem you talk about this it's
it's just like it's so New York City for
me was always I was this I always felt
talk about low self-esteem I always felt
like this guy who is a failure on the
outside looking in what the were those
you're blogging I'm just saying like was
I'm in theater school trying to be an
actor I suck here trying to comedy I
stalk and I and I but finally I got up
and I'd get up on I was doing stuff and
I was like even after MADtv I couldn't
get a job and I was blonde trying to be
a [ __ ] a comic and an actor and if we
said the whole thing was just always
impossible completely and then what
who were like the comics that were in
your class you know say classes yeah I
would get there it was like a dance oder
was around and dances from the same
hometown a Denver area oh nice yeah and
then like Joe list and Sam Morril and
all these killers and then like Michael
che came in and you know Michelle wolf
and people like that but you know I'd
see big J and be like oh I would kill to
be big J wow what a career he's got a
little life so funny and then Mike
Vicky's own was a guy were like oh my
god I could never be that good and
there's all there's so many good guys in
New York who can't get a break they
can't get a special some of them slipped
through like sodas got HBO special
coming out thank but there's a couple
beasts out there that just can't like
who like Vicky's own is like one of the
funniest comics I've ever seen and his
album got voted number one by whatever
the hell and all this and it's so tight
and so good such a great writer but just
nobody can't I don't think ease selling
out or anything so it's tough but then
there's guys like well because you've
been doing it for a while now I feel
like not that you weren't big before but
now it's like especially out here the
scene I hear everyone's talking about
really you and Schultz oh wow who are
the guys were it's like oh yeah they're
the next kind of in line oh oh yeah
that's nice to hear that Schultz is uh
that guy's a freight train of just like
marketing and internet and like getting
eyeballs and exposure like he does all
the clips and now everybody does the
clips you know he's what you get when
you mix a great comedian with a business
mind yes it's rare five field would be
one right where you get the guy singing
do both yeah learning from each other
yeah what you should be doing a lot of
people don't realize that and you know
when I was coming up when Rogen was
coming up when burbs coming up all those
older guys none of us there was no money
to be made in stand yeah there was no
such thing as like theater acts actually
there was very few yeah the most part
and everybody was doing everybody you
did clubs and oh by the way you did you
did local press there was no Facebook
there was no weather there was no
Instagram just different and there and
certainly no one in other countries knew
you there were in a podcast it was kind
of street lifestyle are you just like
under the radar it was fire in a
basement
fine with us so much so that it was such
a grind you were never gonna make money
yeah I'm never gonna make money if you
made five grand in a weekend that was
crazy
so what you do is you do that you do the
college circuit so yeah like a grand and
that was big but that isn't that why you
a lot of comics back then couldn't wait
to jump the TV yeah so yes so you had
guys like Paul Reiser and even Seinfeld
and these guys who once they got inside
well with the exception once they got a
writer similar girl
all these guys once they got times they
got TV you stopped in Roseanne you
stopped I'll keep going you stop doing
mine right yep
and raver I'm styling stand-up basically
because they got a TV show that was the
Holy Grail Kevin James yeah you get you
got the TV show and you were and the
grind was over and I all of us felt that
way I'd be like all I need is this
sitcom yeah and I got a couple big
sitcoms and you'd be like and I remember
going I might be able to just make a lot
of money doing this right and not
getting on a plane on Wednesday and
coming home on Monday right when sunday
shows - and you're making 15 yeah yeah
do you do you want to go to the TV route
- yeah I can't act and I just like doing
stand-up I like writing new jokes I like
the whole I like the road I like clubs
and maybe I'll grow out of that I'm
still you know mid thirties here and I
like to drink and [ __ ] around but such a
common generate oh yeah I like being a
degenerate I don't I don't care for this
clean-cut you know what's that guy
[ __ ] it's like Sebastian he's got
like a wife and kid he's he's a cool
dude and he's killing it he's a
bazillionaire but like I want to get a
little rough and tumble I roll around
then the [ __ ] yeah I like that
I'm from New Orleans I want to you know
if you like the under Tapestry the
sub-tree end up that pretty rug and
getting underneath yeah I remember
seeing Geraldo and be like I like that
like well he's a heroin pillhead I'm
like all right yeah
I don't know anything about what you're
talking about but I got no yeah you were
doing blow back there you know I would
never I never drugged her but I was I
was definitely you were around you get
you get nice and mucky and dirty yeah
something about the road it's something
about nowadays everybody's watching
nowadays if you gets a little Fame
they got Twitter and people are people
like the tattletale yeah cool they're
pretty cool but for the most part it's
true that there's something about just
doing a show in New Orleans where the
[ __ ] you are and go to some dive bar
some speaking just drinking and just
hang for a stick around and you go come
with a takes you you know there's some
fans like I know this pledge like let's
go yeah I've never met you before I'll
never see you again but let's live are
those tips real yeah they're happened am
I going gay tonight you know in my arm
yes I trust you here how wild was it on
the road with Burt oh man well open up
for Burt and Europe 14 nights 14
countries 14 or I guess 28 shows I mean
no break no no I think we had one day
off and we went some strip club and
Copenhagen and had a [ __ ] blast and
he was like facetiming his wife while
getting lapped yeah it was insane so
married but he is very married but I
don't think he knows his kids names it
was just so like I took three years off
my life I was telling you that one kid
came out the last two days and he was
like after the first night he just was
like I'm going home and I was like I did
14 you [ __ ] come on just keep it up
with Burt he's like a 70s celebrity he's
eating a steak at [ __ ] 11 a.m.
drinking a scotch then he goes and works
out and then he comes back and does like
ten marketing things he's editing a
video he's shooting [ __ ] and then we do
the set and he gets blotto all night and
then he does it the next day monster the
monster he man'll gene he's got the
Mickey Mantle
so where's you the key man he totally
does have that I mean he'll die at 49
but ya know we better enjoy it what yeah
yeah enjoy it [ __ ] I saw him yesterday
he's uh he's looking good he's taking
weird where are we where'd you go tell
me the conscience what was your film
country uh well let's see
you know Dublin
Manchester Scotland Amsterdam all all
the Europe ones you know you get loose
in Amsterdam we got loose we've you know
we just did the canals and get a got a
bunch of weed you a drug guy no I'm not
a weed guy I can't do it I'm too [ __ ]
up the weed brings out all the demons
yeah it doesn't suppress I'm like
alcohol what do you like you like booze
and uppers yeah yeah but yours not
because you don't seem like lost you
have your darkness it's from your
childhood I think so yeah I had a weird
childhood how so well let's see my dad
got a wild hair up his ass and bought a
mansion dilapidated mansion a poor black
neighborhood so first of all the house
was [ __ ] we barely had running water
it was you know we'd have family
meetings all right go [ __ ] at school
don't [ __ ] here we need the water and
then my dad started running out of money
so he made the back half of bed and
breakfast like old-style bit so my mom's
whipping up pancakes at 8 a.m. and I'm
like can I get one she's like blow a big
dick eat them full of Cheerios you [ __ ]
and smells like alright sorry Jesus and
so you you know there's soap my peers
are workaholics they're checked out you
know there were nice people but they're
just like hey we gave birth to you you
figure yeah go watch TV
there's no attention yes dr. drew
adjusting to happen to a [ __ ] common
baby but boy so what doctor do say so he
said you're because I was like my mom
didn't react like I have girlfriends
I'll introduce it or my mom they're like
whoa that was tough feel like I was
bombing in there I'm like welcome to my
life
you [ __ ] [ __ ] Jesus Christ I'm 20
years of that [ __ ] growing up and laughs
from [ __ ] strings yeah like ask me a
questions ask me a random question I'm
my mom um random question where are you
from what time is it it's just like oh
[ __ ] sorry I'm engaged yeah and it's
just not mean she's just like she's just
got her checked out yeah she's just like
thinking about all right I got to pay
the bill I got a lot of the plants you
know and your legs you have brothers and
sisters older brother and he's a genius
he's like this you know math of computer
wizard and our neighborhood was so
dangerous and he just head into a
computer like as a kid and he just
became like Dass and she made friends in
the neighbourhood with the block yeah
yeah
but then you got into fights and there
was a lot of racial tension it was the
90s and bikes were stolen and we got
robbed all the time we had this crazy
alarm going off because our house was so
big and you would just I'd be like an
eight-year-old kid you just hear like
glass breaking and then I'm just like oh
I'm in my room like huggin up Teddy you
know hoping I don't get raped by [ __ ]
Leroy and you know you go downstairs and
hey the TV's gone today you know and
that was that was a Tuesday yeah we got
robbed all the time my dad he's got like
he's like n-word rich you know where
he's like I were gonna buy a shitty
Lexus but it's Alexis you know so the
Lexus would get stolen he's like all
right he'll you give me like cab money
to go to school and [ __ ] and and that
was just how it was I remember I told
this story on Rogan but I got my bike
stolen just just street tuff's you know
they would rub their front tire on your
back tire and that meant like you're
[ __ ] and they would just take your
bike and you know you could try to fight
him but there was like three 17 year old
kids without dads you know you're gonna
give him your bike yeah and say you you
you get comedy early you know yeah and
they you try to be funny in a public
school and all that but I went to an
all-black public school it was pretty
mixed but it was it was a New Orleans
does have a lot of racial tension oh
yeah oh yeah what's the South you know
and there's so much poverty there is
it's like tourism tourism tourism and
then the rest of the cities kind of
neglect Miami's like that it's so poor
yeah a black neighborhoods it's just so
[ __ ] it's crazy
how'd you out what your relationship
with your dad and mom now we're we're
cool but it's almost co-worker like are
they still in New Orleans yeah yeah yeah
they're in that engine
no they're - two guys broke in with guns
and tied them up and like took all the
jewelry and the credit cards and the car
keys and so they really like that's
about it what's that would they let him
go they let him go but you know it might
be they untie themselves the 20 minutes
after they left and they like you know
he's my dad's like chewing the [ __ ]
ropes he's like that's that's yeah
that's what did it so they were like
yeah we should move and we got robbed a
zillion times but I walked in on a few
robberies yeah cuz you know I see you're
so young and a juvenile you don't know
what's happening so they'd be like a big
guy with a like a TV under his arm and
he's like oh we're your parents I'm like
oh let me go get my dad
and the house was so big I would run to
the other side of the house and I member
looking out of the window and I saw him
running through the backyard with the TV
and I was like huh that's weird the
house was huge huge house like we had a
wing with wings Wow yeah yeah not a
great podcast say hey you know bad move
to be the first one who's McDuck to the
hood yeah and so everybody thought we
were loaded because you know we were the
white family in the mansion with the
lake what did they show what did he do
to buy that mansion do they have money
to begin well it was so rundown that I
think he's like I got a [ __ ] steal on
this was like a foreclosure maybe yeah
well I think and the neighborhood was so
shitty and it was such a shitty build
that he was like I think he got it for
dirt cheap I remember one time we called
the cops so much they knew us they're
like other Norman's and so eventually
they're like you know what let's go
sleep or stakeout in the kitchen and
we'll actually be there if a guy comes
and catch them that's how frequently we
were getting robbed they're like let's
stakeout in the kitchen so I was like
this is so exciting I'm ten years old
there's two [ __ ] grizzled cops in my
kitchen and I'm like this excited I hope
they bust the guy and I went downstairs
like 7:00 in the morning I ran down
expecting to see some guy in cuffs and
the cops had ransacked the whole pantry
eating everything out of the fridge we
got robbed again the cops took all the
pancakes the pop-tarts cinnamon toast
crunch those [ __ ] pigs and they
hightailed out of there at 6:00 a.m.
goddamn yeah I mean what age did you
leave New Orleans I got I did University
of New Orleans but I was such a drunk
piece of [ __ ] that I just I got like
straight FS and my parents like you got
a figure something out so I went to
Community College Baton Rouge I would
have gotten I would have gotten three
police dogs three German Shepherds it'd
be nice we like that yeah I would be I'd
have [ __ ] no if you don't buy that
mansion and think like that yeah exactly
and there were those no most look like I
get my bike stole and they're like what
happened I'm like God these two kids you
know they were like poor kids and they
were like yeah they need it they need it
more than us like I all right yeah whose
side you taking here mom yeah you know
and that's why you grow up with low
self-esteem yeah like a low self-worth
like that's why people go mad you have
so many jokes in your act I'm like yeah
and these people came out and are paying
money I can't let them down I gotta
[ __ ] bring it yeah you know I see a
lot of conquer that what else is going
on am i doing what are you crazy this
cut got a babysitter bring the heat you
can come stain let's go free I [ __ ]
agree with that it's cause your audience
exactly I I couldn't agree more
they valeted you know like I'm not gonna
not every [ __ ] time you got people in
pain there it's costing them $100 for
that night no it won't you let them down
they might come back get my [ __ ] show
who do you think you are who do you
think dance mommy sit on the stool I go
yeah well I figured out this all day my
brother I suggestion in New York all
talk I'm not gonna mention names but
there were plenty of like the big one
time yeah the big ten guys do that yes
they can do the [ __ ] did not really know
because well you see people go what the
[ __ ]
I guess oh yeah and last I'd watch them
and I'd be like you guys are [ __ ]
sitting there you ever said one funny
thing right right whole time get the
[ __ ] it's so entitled it's like hey you
you're here to see me just look at me no
I'm sorry Jane you're not important
Brendan and I were talking about this
rather than I were talking about how all
of us are so eminently and immediately
replaceable
oh yeah no yeah I can hit by a bus
walking out here if I get if I go away
oh [ __ ] really I liked him pass the salt
please
yeah exactly you're not important yeah
we're all in a conveyor belt I mean look
at this store is just a one great calm I
got during it would that's how it should
be
I agree the other thing is about doing
like you know I was thinking about this
I was up in a lineup with Bill burr Ali
Wong Sebastian Maniscalco
I don't know the list goes on you can't
go up by reason not Bobby Lee you can't
go up there and not bring the goods
yeah it's good luck it's embarrassing
and that might be a new a certain title
coding these younger folk and I hate to
sound like grandpa Norman but like they
kind of have this entitlement like [ __ ]
I forgot was gonna say damn about not
bringing the goods not getting what oh
wait what did you say I was saying about
you got all your gonna back I got it
back
yeah I gotta stop jerking off and they
bomb they bomb horribly and they just
fluff it off like I'm like ooh if I bomb
like that I would be in the back cutting
myself yeah what are you crazy you
should we should hate yourself and
should go home and think about what you
did and work on and yeah week it and
change it and listen yep they don't care
that so that's math cow Cobra cords a
semi and on the way home he listens to
it there you go
[ __ ] yeah yeah and it pays off like the
more work you put in the better you'll
do it and that comes from not really
liking yourself that much sometimes
comes try agree okay pressure of not not
failing
- that's Mormon yeah like just realizing
that it's always gonna be hard and it's
never you never arrived with car you're
chasing a dragon yes you say some a
dragon it is also why it's great because
you can't you know sometimes you beat a
video game the first day or like well
that was dumb yeah Nina you gotta keep
going like that's what Dave Attell hates
himself causing LLL kill with great
meteo me like I'm a hack I suck like
what what the fact do you think that is
why you're great brother well I heard
that my friend we used to wait on
Joaquin Phoenix uh he was a regular the
Joker and was that yellow Joker oh yeah
and he he had done I guess he had been
nominated for walk the line right for
Johnny Cash and my friend just couldn't
take it anymore he goes hey dude I just
want you to know and my friends a good
actor and now it's doing well but he
said he goes this way you know you were
so good in that and what came - no stop
stop I'm a terrible actor I can't I came
there you go I love that he was like oh
now he's also probably a little crazy
he's a little nutty yet but it's also
what drives him sure Seymour Hoffman
ever was like that - and look where he
turned out great he sure did hung out I
saw it met him a week before he he went
away and oh yeah he was he was the color
in New York hello I was and I was at the
shots on my mom with John Leguizamo and
he came up I met Sean Penn that morning
pretty cool droppin names I know all
over yeah I know right - course mom - I
was so cool I was like jeez you know I'm
Sean Penn and I'm a huge fan and then
Philip Seymour Hoffman came up with a
cigarette it's not nervous your
arthritis
yeah oh my god it probably figure out
what all right we can do that yeah but
it never it never was he ever bad in a
movie was he ever channel told Kalyan
movie or was he always amazing it's
always honey he held all the show up
Boogie Nights he was always like yeah I
was good actor killer as good an actor
as it gets luckily we have Gaffigan who
can who looks just like another beast
yeah we ain't that funny you mentioned
Sean Penn with a cigarette isn't it
funny now how much it's all changed like
older guys are badasses you know like
when you were younger old guys like hey
you know button your shirt and comb your
hair and get a haircut kid and now old
guys are like at least young kids are
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know know
everybody's eating kale and not smoking
and there's all these comics are sober
now and everything it's kind of flipped
in like old is cool now yeah and oldest
tough old it's tough oldest tough kids
are not tough now younger people are not
tough at all
they're craley we had a war now who
knows what happened you know it'll be
like uh the III was the gluten got me
you know we can just throw peanuts at
the [ __ ] troops he's really strong
technology I saw I went to pitch them at
Netflix the other day boy did I bomb
that pitch I can't pitch the show it's
brutal yeah piss the guy off with in
like four seconds Mike super politically
right now i alt left Oh was that just
homeboy controller dropping the n-word
oh maybe maybe he said the n-word he
didn't say this yeah oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah and he said let's not say this
word yeah they said the word yeah
awesome but uh exist Netflix is
literally has a credo they'll tell you
oh yeah they have quotas they're locked
in no you have a TV show we have an
Asian director we have a woman director
there so it's not doesn't matter it's
it's it's less about what happened in
your so I had two good pitches before
that so I was loose and I was zinging
and Zhang and I was I was on and we were
in there with the Netflix guy and we
couldn't get the video to work to play
the sizzle and it was just showing like
the ceiling and I go it's the Kevin
Hart's x2 I'm trying to make joke
can you believe that the woman is suing
him for that I was like well I think
it's the best thing he's ever done it's
funny it's funny than his specials and
he was like you know I produced the last
four of those I don't think that's
appropriate I mean he does he works with
NetFlow like oh yeah I'm just calm just
busting balls I love Kevin Hart I wish I
was in he's a little guy and cute and
all that pets to go see it he just the
whole pitch oh I poured my heart out in
this pitch shucking and jiving I'm tap
dancing and he was just like thank you
take a joke she's doing something right
though aren't they I mean what do you
think catch up with it might it might
catch up yeah you catch knees jumping
into it get these other streaming
service jumping yeah they're gonna have
some competition
nah dude Disney doesn't miss me see what
own Netflix is how you do it cool and
then they took all their stuff back and
start doing specials yeah well Netflix
now has become a place where it's all
original content right you can't find no
they have other stuff like their friends
on their slime field are losing friends
aren't they I think but they still have
they still have contracts other stuff oh
yeah they're uh yeah just like anything
they're the cream of the crop now but
the big boys are gonna come into yeah
it's gonna level out without the only
game it's all good for us it's all right
there's so many space is the podcasting
stand-up we are we are we are in a
really good finance like this is where
you want to be for the next ten years I
yeah it's bittersweet because you got to
do the tweeting and this and that but
then you could also have control of your
whole you know art form this is first
time ever in my in my in my career and
in show business where artists have this
much control yeah and where they're
making all the money it's crazy it's
crazy how much money these comics are
making oh not me but it's nuts wildest
it's the new rock stars is this its what
rock stars were like now as a comic you
can sell if you can sell 5,000 10,000
tickets which a lot of our friends are
yeah it's sky's the limit
oh yeah it's surprising they let
Chappelle and bird still rock out at
Netflix because they're the opposite of
that yeah but that's why opium to Rogen
- yeah but if you got the numbers I
guess the numbers the number I'm being a
little unfair that's true but you know
what I mean leave you got the fan like
Chappelle and rogue are doing arenas you
know but I think Netflix is also I think
what Netflix says I don't know how alt
left are what I meant is that Nemzek
yeah I did this is you yeah it's true
it's true I am backpedaling a little
people actually what they were saying is
listening what they were saying is the
old studio system is dead and we want to
revolutionize the way things are done
yes so you know in that sense drone that
I reason I like that more people jump
into the pool so you have options you
don't want someone just dominate where
if you're not on Netflix like I you're
not really doing well right I'm with you
yeah now you don't want Netflix have to
say like let's say they pass on mark or
they pass on you right they passed on
you it's like and me both you yeah so
that's like what the that doesn't make
sense to great comics I'd look at the
other people on there those people are
awful man if funny is the 14th thing on
the list now you know it's like what
color are you what do you have between
your legs
what do you identify as how many Twitter
how many this how's your podcast and
then funny how do you think I got a
special there you go great car though
red Ferrari unreal sexy sexy man who's
got a can beat up everybody - I know you
got an you're so nice yeah you got it
all I'm all right you don't chat
roulette oh yeah what is this 1999 I I
we just learned on Monday and we put
chin was doing it and all the guys are
just passed and I was like okay so you
cat took one for the team she got on
there literally right do chatroulette
and we're fishing for a dick yeah we got
one within two seconds this guy he goes
right to the guy the guy goes
man must be nice see dicks are so thick
falling out of the sky that it got no
they've got no currency like they're
like stock yeah dropping its - it's easy
to buy with vagina it's it's worth it's
like gold
you know we're dicks like aluminum
chatroulette let me take a piss before
we do gotta Chris - all right you guys
I'll hold it down
stamps.com [ __ ] me undies blue chu
expressvpn away bags sometimes you need
somebody who's a professional just talk
to each other cuz I don't know how you
know what happens why I got a pro if I
have a problem we've done this
I got a problem I'm going through
something the problem is we don't know
it's like there's nothing to say I don't
have answers Bros so we don't talk talk
to somebody else dudes don't talk if I
call Brennan and I go hey dude can you
talk I'm sad he's gonna go oh you have
the wrong number
cuz it's awkward okay I go you all say
you'll be yeah cuz we don't know and
sometimes you need but who's your aunt's
mental how who try and hit them you need
experience mental present promise
slicing that bills out of 220 an hour
nobody has that kind of money to talk to
out like a counselor not up in here
guess what better help here comes
technology here comes the web you can
start communicating to somebody who's a
licensed professional therapist real 424
hours it's not a crisis line world does
not help it's professional counseling
done securely online there's a broad
range of expertise and better helps
counselor network go to it and you'll
see it got a better help calm and thus
and it's available worldwide cuz well
that's what the internet is
well you FaceTime with maybe your girl
maybe your bros maybe your parents they
stop it's basically FaceTime with a
therapist you can 24/7 you can log into
your account anytime send a message to
your counselor you'll get timely
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule a weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room we see
people you might know last time for that
go to better help calm slash fighter
join the over 500,000 people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of experienced professionals
fighter and the kid listeners T back
guarantee listeners get 10% off your
first month talking to therapists better
help calm slash fighter dude I like
fighting I like football I like
basketball I like baseball
alright money money so I want to watch
the game I want to bet on it but I want
to know who I lay my money down with I'm
gonna get my money back you want to mind
where your mouth is bro yeah bro and I'm
gonna bet my money with my bookie my
bookie I'm specific things like
game-winning touchdowns on 2-minute
drives all kinds of like you can break
it down right yeah you do the smart
thing go to my bookie AG no one gives
you more ways to win than they do my
bookies got the fastest payouts and
better lines than any other sports Burk
do the smart thing do the smart thing if
you're gonna bet this football season
bet with my book make money on the NFL
season UFC whatever you want whatever
your soccer football as you Brits call
it anything you want whatever dude join
now in my book you will double your
first deposit use promo code fighter to
activate the offer that's promo code
fighter visit my bookie Agee today you
play you win you paid you get paid get
paid watch sports and get paid hey B if
you like me back in the day back in the
day before I met you yeah before I met
you dude I'm not always paying attention
my bank account I'm not always do it
sometimes overdrawn you know it's a lot
of money on overdraft fees yes he said
you end up spending $37 you did it in
half maybe maybe buy a cup of coffee
overdrawn 37 dollars for a cup of coffee
what are we doing you a hundred dollars
for that talk to you K you kidding it's
like it's like when video remember when
you you wouldn't return and you get you
they make their money on late fees yeah
well that's what everyone's doing not
anymore thanks to Dave Dave app is he
hey Dave just like Dave can't spot Jim
probably be handling money Dave app put
an end to overdraft fees for good dave
is the number one budging app in America
because it saves you from overdraft
fee's tells you about upcoming bills and
can advance you $75 and it doesn't drive
and there's no interest dude get the
Dave app and for just $1 per month $1
that's 12 hours a year which is way less
than over Daffy just one fee pays for
that you got to pay
one you pay one again you'll never pay
an overdraft fee again it helps you
budget for upcoming expenses text you if
you're spending too much save text you
right now Dave text me if you need fast
cash you know in advance advance you $75
in just 90 second about this Mart queue
and never heard of that billionaire he's
an investor in Dave he believes in it
yeah cuz he got overdraft fees when he
was younger we all do we've been there
go to Dave comm /f ATK and really
heavily the show if you let them know
you heard from here download Dave and
never pay for another overdraft fee
again to mediate savings go now
Dave dot-com / fa renamed people already
use Dave to save up to $1,000 a year yes
draft fees well number one budgeting app
in the App Store number one da be e Dave
com /f ATK let's do this guy's talks
Matt he's talking about height talk
about lying talking about lying all
kinds of stuff what do you guys got so
just an update from the other day story
about that resource officer who arrested
the six year old girl and the eight year
old boy he has officially been fired
yeah of course he's dumb wait what hat
what he do so this is six year old huh I
don't know that we're having a temper
tantrum what he would say it looks
identical to Cleveland family again he's
just not smart you gotta get that guy
out of it he's gonna do something even
more stupid yeah wait are we on we're on
oh yeah and there's one detail I left
out of the story from two days ago which
was the grandmother when she picked up
the little girl said that she was
probably acting out because she has
sleep apnea and wasn't sleeping well to
which the officer then responded I also
have sleep apnea I don't go around
kicking
Cleveland you are 47 years oh what a
disaster he's just I don't know I think
we need black cops just you know to a
level it out with the shootings you know
let him kill the kid and then we're back
you know I hope the kid was white it
that he shoots cuz then you know black
as well I was alright so look it's not a
racial thing we just cops like shooting
people at hey take it likes to shoot
yeah
did you see Jeezy that cop that I think
it was in LA was it in LA with the cop
that thought she was in her apartment
oh yeah but you she was it and shot the
button Texas wish it was text listen
shot the the black guy yeah apartment
god I mean is anybody buying that that
she went to the well the floors and
you're tired I mean I can happen but
really something's up there's no no
there was a new detail that came out
about that case recently where they look
through her phone records and within the
time that that all went down she was
sexting somebody so they're saying she
was in a compromised state of mind
because if you're like busy and doing
something walking someone a rock hard
drive done it that's a tragedy
you're really you've done it I have done
that yeah let's shot a black yeah I've
tried to get into the wrong I've been
texting went to the wrong car I can't
believe it now yeah like a bunch of
girls lined up at the road or just
Tuesday night that was Burton girl girls
white girls line up for mark no no I'm
I'm a child but L see good okay just a
heads up this one is a very sad one
alright they don't have too much behind
the reason why the father did this but
in New York a father held on to his
daughter and jumped on to the train
tracks before a train came and hit home
luckily she hit the floor flat and he
was killed but she was fine she just had
some bruising and some kinda train went
over her over the dad yeah and she was
underneath the deck he was trying
savor know something with you want to
commit suicide oh [ __ ] I'm jealous of
the connection they had at least you
know my dad was uh he wasn't hugging at
least she got a hug out of it yeah well
that's you're making this about you and
I don't know you're right you're right
it's still video is of the little girl
crawling out from oh yeah I'd rather
watch today get hit by the train than
the little girl yeah same same just put
on some kiddie porn okay good both be
riding a train this whole thing the
wrong way dude so a man in Texas went
and divorced his wife without her
knowledge and now police officers are
looking for him because he went to a
notary and forged her signature while
she was married to Frederick Douglass
this is a long time yeah she's married
to cleanse Portus that's cool I think
that's kind of fun that's how I would
divorce a wife he's my age doesn't look
bad and she didn't know about the
divorce until a couple months later when
she noticed him buying jewelry on his
credit card statements asking him what
it was for he said I don't need to tell
you we're divorced and yes she had takes
two to tango yeah works for signature so
see I'm a guy I'll be in a relationship
miserable I was in a 13-year
relationship which should have ended at
seven but I just was like I don't want
to dump anybody that's mean even sevens
being generous you know play yeah I got
three in probably yeah high school
sweetheart the whole thing but I what am
I gonna hurt somebody's feelings yeah so
eventually I just kind of checked out a
mint emotionally and she she dumped me
are you good at like brick breakups can
you just break up words that's what I'm
saying I couldn't do it now you drag it
out I dry I'll just I'll just marry her
and be miserable forever yeah yeah I
won't hurt somebody speak yeah somebody
crying
yeah somebody yes that's why don't you
fight people I would just like I love
you babes uh what are we doing he's like
that actually yeah I've been a much
better fighter if I was meaner yeah yeah
I don't want to hurt you when you leave
when you would practice you would never
now don't that I just hated it yeah
cyfle you said this great joke about how
it's just weird the two guys fight like
she'd at least getting like a little car
wreck and then fight you know because
you need some animosity I know well a
lot of the good fighters create that
animosity TLDs he's an angry guy I know
a lot a lot of them view it is just it's
just what they do they don't need to
animosity got those crazy rose don't
need the animosity but like khabib you
can see he's like I really want to [ __ ]
this guy up so he's I have played to
though he's like well of course he's
there to just he's weren't there to win
yeah Sports Gary guy what does she get
yeah
hey can I just say one thing this is the
Colorado shooter that this school
shooter this one I'm number three did
you see what they're doing the movie
just had a girl or a guy that's a guy
right girl - right oh boy what pronoun
should we use Devon Eriksen I think
that's a guy jay-z just for to section
suspects in the deadly Colorado shooting
oh [ __ ] this today no this is months ago
okay you never know it's shootings many
ways that would be that's what that was
him
that got killed oh yeah it's like Louis
CK's joke defect committed County
Courthouse in Castle Rock Colorado with
the latest Alicia I John the CCO is
being called a celebration of life and
the procession will be led by the
Douglas County Sheriff's Department it's
the first time they've done so for
civilian the 18 talked about his funeral
oh yeah who helped uh did you see the
movie The Joker because yeah is this one
your kernel alright I'll save it move on
I think I know you're gonna say but I'm
excited to see it everybody's raving
about it Aurora or the shine they're not
going to show it there's a bunch of
theaters doing it oh ah because they're
worried that the sort of movie for
whatever reason the character Joker is
like the
instead it's like the Harry Seinfeld of
comedy for mass shooters in some ways
maybe I know that maybe I don't but in a
way it's like almost there is probably
some be in the movie you know oh you are
oh yeah oh cool man Congrats yeah this
is gonna be a big hit you might get a
ticket yeah you never know it would have
been it would be central city's not
gonna do it right because last time
there's the Joker movie there Batman
Begins there's the mass shooting yes la
aurora studios it's the century yes yeah
ah the movie yeah I can see that being
an issue you think in like a hundred
years we'll go to the Aurora theater
like it like people go to Auschwitz
you know you think it'll be like a
landmark no there's too many on that's
too many you're right yeah good point
it's it's it's normal now yeah no one's
going to Sandy Hook the flavor of the
week yeah fortunately it's a bummer in
that wild yeah
weird I wonder if shooters talk about it
it's like comedy like man I'm acting you
know like people talk about Carson you
don't have anybody to talk to they're
usually Oklahoma wow you don't know they
have group chats now that's where they
organize things and get ideas here's the
program well it's not the promise thing
you're not they're not getting famous
anymore and so I'm saying used to get
famous from me yeah how like we know the
Columbine shoe is the first one right
you know those dumbasses exactly now
like the media's savvy to it like oh
this what they want so you don't see
their face right that's the first time
I've seen that [ __ ] up [ __ ] with the
die here name who shot the stem I don't
I can tell you his name ladyboys most
their names but I'm saying you did cars
in the 80s you were famous overnight it
was like a school shooting now as a
comic no one cares it's like school
shooters you know yeah no one cares no
one cares dude there's too many it's too
many it used to break you yep now it
doesn't look now I got Andrew Schultz
and just you know put your shootings on
line I mean yeah this is why I'm bombing
my Netflix Olsen what does he get this
is okay this is a trailer we'll be able
to show a little bit of it
it's Adam Sandler's new movie yeah
alright so it's a serious role have you
seen sail around New York you know dude
I just saw him yesterday in the Netflix
Dale office I gotta say this he's
wearing a t-shirt basketball shorts and
flip-flops
I was like man did he make it yes I mean
I'm shaking in my boots I'll have mr.
Netflix how you doing who is this
Sandler Sandman just hanging out in the
lobby like he is Netflix they said he's
like a 12 movie deal [ __ ] hell he
always wears baggy clothes yeah that's
for the and is that right see this
interesting see we all wear life flaws
we're all human I love when he does
drama brunch Drunk Love Benglis English
is great water boy oh he's got a tutor
Oh vibe huh Kevin Garnett that's Frank
what's-his-face he's the he was the
manager for the Mets there you go oh
she's in Wow how do you know frozen
stars oh yeah three year old oh you do
snowman thinks she's sexy man the kid
idina menzel oh I thought you meant
three years [ __ ] sexy did your voices
I think he's just hot I just don't I
agree I got crazy jaw yep yes she's of a
job I like I like a big big mug she
looks Israeli chicks are the beautiful
greatly that Israeli to do to American
Jew real drop off maybe I don't know
nothing about the Jew blood and that the
homeland
yeah it's pure then they come here and
they put them yes like allergies and
[ __ ] I can't touch a milk no see alright
the next one sorry I'm talking about the
internet not working don't ever
apologize
yeah working it was like Stalin
Centralia I'm gonna watch that watch
that - when's that come out but only 20
it's on that's right yes of course
Netflix dance awesome man who lost
rocker okay so this is uh this is from
Ashley marks hood Louisiana
love he tried to propose to his
girlfriend on a hotel you know hotels
that are under
water it's like the windows you can see
the water like to land it like Atlantis
or like yeah he gone yeah he went under
the water and then proposed his
girlfriend by diving I'm confused
I'll show you the tank he's outside the
tank she's inside a hotel that's
underwater underwater oh and he did with
paper yes and this isn't antonia tans
believe it was Tanzania where's Tanzania
I don't know ah I see I don't feel so
bad if the asian guy couldn't he
couldn't get out no so he actually did
the whole proposal and then he never
ended up going back up he never surfaced
ah
that's in there yeah that's the note
that's a long note I can't hold my
breath long enough to tell you
everything I love about you but
everything I loved by you I loved more
every day so he did this that's a lot of
work yeah
will you marry me don't know why that's
plain yeah that's more than you've
written in a year god dammit dude how
did he die so it's still kind of weird
they don't they don't know exact causes
yet who dr. C I blame the lady he's
backup though he came back out let me
show you this yeah the one things we
always got each other yeah we see that
you see that the the [ __ ] it went
viral I think Kristina P posted the
Segura's wife she was making fun of it
it's pretty funny but this lady's going
through pregnancy and the guys like like
has a [ __ ] novel no oh he's like
saying all this stuff doing this and
she's going through pregnancy oh it was
so intense you [ __ ] us dude yeah all
the chicks see that exactly and we don't
wanna get married in the first place you
[ __ ] if we're do all this [ __ ] for you
I don't want to do this underwater yeah
ah so check out this video real quick
you popped the question I'm not to
mention we break up to get all the money
proposal
it's a lose-lose it went horribly wrong
this Louisiana is for a lifelong memory
damn Steven Weber and his girlfriend
kanesha Antoine were in a racist Africa
that's the room right there see if that
features and I was pretty cool yeah I
said I don't like a relaxed one who was
inside at the time she was Webber
outside one of the rooms windows 30 feet
underwater holding a hand roadie feet I
didn't realize is that there's pretty
low down was about you yeah how deep is
your love
where defeat that's what he started go
up and that was it
uh he should have gone scuba hurts from
the steps so you never got to hear my
answer
yeah and that's her she posted on her
Facebook my god [ __ ] baller what a
disaster sees this the only one worse
the only you know what the only I've
told you about this the only one wants
that scene this is when that couple just
got married and they jumped in a Viper
those dodge vipers are squirrelly yeah
it's like have a good life he's all
thanks know right in the wall damn
that's poor Viper are you [ __ ]
kidding me through the drive yeah Jesus
30 feet Elmo there's the fail your
limits
you a story about Klee abyss and
cleaveth Crichton two sons like this is
an old story Sons I say their mother is
their mother the the chariot the horse
is sick the mother is a good woman
she's got perfect sons and she wants to
go to the temple to pray to Hera and and
Zeus his wife and give alms and the
brought the but son said mother we will
take you and they're the exemplary of
like two perfect sons and they strap the
[ __ ] chariot to their chest and they
run her for miles in the heat to - you
know - so she can pray in time to Hera
mother gets there and the brothers
they're so exhausted that's taken map
under a tree and they're like okay mom
goes the praised a header there better
be a path in the face she says and it
says all I ask and Harrises you're good
she comes to us as you're a good woman
and she was what can I do for your piety
and she says all I ask is that my sons
die the happiest of men hmm of course of
course her sons never wake up ah it's a
miscarriage it's a miscarriage damn Wow
Hannah [ __ ] can happen look you died
happy right
Diddy don't panic Yeah right [ __ ]
[ __ ] panic oh I [ __ ] up I'm not that
good of a swimmer I'm 30 feet deep
that's yeah the irony is the black woman
isn't the bad swimmer and she's alive hi
this is hold on mark that's not how to
readings class all right I'm sure you
saw sorry until you're Brown this is
from 2018 though which he's alleged to
have a trash the condo that he paid
$35,000 a month for that's his condo
trash right but the here's a problem he
was thrown allegedly throwing furniture
outside the window where people were oh
this guy's a kook huh are you a sports
fan yeah yeah most comics aren't I feel
it's true yeah landing in the pool on
the pool deck
cranly I guess you can see the items
here wanted the hole you're falling at a
luxurious hotel in condo in Atlanta
tonight and there's families and
sunbathers look up and then run from
what's coming down damn there was even
kids what are you on - so he could have
[ __ ] you say it's it's not him like
someone broke into his place
no definitely we have footage of another
person expect you all you don't see him
thrown in no why would he do that cuz
he's a [ __ ] he's the same guy that
threatened in a group chat to the lady
that's suing him for sexual assault he
grouped chattered threatened her life
doesn't think things through does he
know didn't he rape a couple people as
well yes proper glass another chair
little mind as long as I don't think a
guy like this would do this yeah well he
was okay lost sixty million dollars this
year that guy so wait do you have it cuz
I got beat up a lot as a kid
do you have that let's say he heard you
say that he's a [ __ ] and he was like I
want to fight you
would that make you nervous not Brendon
it would make me nervous for sure but
I'd probably be tomorrow you think so me
you'd beat me up yeah no no I'm saying
you looking at me I would be doing my
own yeah but I don't know but I don't
want to hear it I don't player don't
forget I mean he's a large look at me
right O'Neil small though
oh hey it doesn't matter he fought in
UFC 16 pro fights I'm aware nobody has
priors me training he doesn't matter he
would take any of those guys if they
were they gonna do tackle baby
okay so take whoever you want to eat the
toughest guy in the NFL JJ what good
what about Cam Newton crazy corn awesome
let's go uh-oh tight Enders okay Glover
alright Glover there we go okay so ready
no Donald right Donald huge relief right
[ __ ] your mom yeah Brennan dressed like
this hasn't fought forever and that's so
the guy comes at Brennan you smash them
against the wall a big problem guess
what
look at that yeah just going to sleep
there's none of the technique right I'm
gonna take me yeah he's also as strong
as those guys coming right now
I mean I like that anymore that's a
different guy well okay it would be
Reggie Bush yeah yeah yeah well he's a
big stoner that's true know that they're
free so if he oh I don't like people
being mad at me before Eisen idiot he's
an idiot
you know I guess the only problem if
they train forever but I mean if they
just come at him in their football
players did against the guy who UFC
veteran whose beds who's been fighting
who has 16 pro fights and there are
heavyweights like Brennan who's to seven
I just a one-day problems you know I
love that you're defending your your boy
here I'm just saying like you can punch
him in the face he punched his feet put
his fist or his elbow right through his
face but it'd be nice to have that gene
is my point of like oh yeah I could beat
that guy up I'm not worried I'm worried
about you know they let nerd in the
hallway out there on the computer that
we've doing test the other day Brendan
is in is a guy who is one of those rare
guys who in any situation if you're in a
room with seven people he could lock the
door and kill everybody was very unless
you're in the room of UFC heavyweight
yeah then I grab a little diamond even
bet you it like you're even good UFC
guys right now who are 155 like you know
really good guys they're tiny they're
not they're not beating Brennan in a
fight I don't care how famous oh wow
already would be to give me to fight
somebody mark I get I'm I'm worthy on
that at the same boat I do some people
do forget that about him about his is
the fact that he's a gorilla a man
gorilla yeah and we'll we'll think
gorilla you know they're crest gorilla
when I knew that with him was when he
was fighting actually I think you had
just stopped hurt no you were fighting
and we were rolling jujitsu and a giant
Samoan professional black belt
professional fighter heavyweight fighter
most terrifying goes like this he got
the thick pine this guy was gonna breath
this guy was big and just an athlete and
he goes like this he goes sob and waves
him over to roll with him hmm
and I go oh geez and Brendan looks at me
he goes watch this I know he's in black
but he goes oh I know
it doesn't matter mmm and then I watch
Brennan beep is that right and shares
Wow Sippi that leg
Wow I was like oh oh but that's what you
got a little bit like a Mark Hunt you
know he's just like flabby is he stable
you kill you kill you kill just nothin
he's got an iron jaw and he's got those
[ __ ] this way do you watch fighting -
yeah yeah really yeah I just watched it
on YouTube all day
I don't really catch it on when it's on
but I'm I'm up to snuff on what's your
sport uh no I like what basketballs far
the most entertaining I got it and
Dominic soo if he decided to start
fighting it well any of those guys Oh
Donald diesel can reek yeah oh yeah this
is a quick one so that making a murderer
saga no boy but this is a director from
a new series that's coming out all right
I need something he's saying that
someone that he talked to in prison
confessed to killing that girl too
recent Halbach so it's not those two
guys are in prison right now Brendan
Brendan Dassey and uh that [ __ ] the
other guy have this guy that's the guy
gray Steven en Gelfand I just want to
get yeah I should I get famous enough to
be the most famous now you're not saying
yeah ready to acid he's killing it what
do you think and I'd this is me getting
all deep and gay but what do you think
it's billing about with we're obsessed
with Ted Bundy true crime murdering and
then you say I'm like that black
swimming joke I made will get you in
more people we're so obsessed with blood
and murder and like Michael Jackson's
molesting kids let's watch that dock yes
we'd love dark shits like we don't feel
anymore you know raving hey you know
what since I was listening to Jack
Shepherd on armchair expert he was
saying how he played this role on
Netflix where it was a extreme like
right role like the whole collar right
stream alright super extreme all right
yeah and his friends acting friends like
famous actor like I can't believe you
play that he goes yeah but two months
ago you guys were celebrating that I got
an offer to play Ted Bundy exactly
that's cereal that's a great point
Oh fantastic good point he playing all
right in front in the show you wouldn't
do that
all right all right easy
that is Madison Tom because that's
because some people are dumb I think a
lot of people are that's mostly their
side he's like it's you I think there's
a book called the madness of crowds
which I'm about to read crowds and
crowds oh crap and and it's it's like
any men nowadays this this hard left or
this weird thing where where there's
this orthodoxy and if you violate yeah
you're dragged up onto the altar of of
the politically correct and it doesn't
matter how non racist you are doesn't
matter who you are if you in any way
vibe cuz its virtue signaling where
everybody wants to be the one to catch
the races and even though they and so
but go after people who aren't even
racist they're just be like you said
that I'm not a rights look I caught that
person is outraged and then you make
sure we get mob mentality yeah so
straight John they do not students of
history but Annunaki people yes some
interest there like I'm really not doing
it well educated and I talk to a lot of
them on this my old podcast all the
well-educated means that they are
[ __ ] they are that doesn't mean
they're smart it means they have an
orthodoxy it means they are vicious a
lot let's do it doesn't mean they're
good people it just means that they are
they are ideologues that they are when
you're really educating you living out
an outlaw in a [ __ ] University you're
surrounded by walls you're surrounded by
walls and no one really you're
surrounded by all these people and you
better toe the line or the same opinion
yeah yeah green emerges yes try finding
a conservative economist economics
professor at an Ivy League school
I'll find them for you but they're
they're relegated to the [ __ ] dark
closet over there it's fed this is newer
right though humanities is almost all
hard left
people like anybody who teaches you know
sociology even history they're all
Marxists yeah but do you think being in
the middle would actually be considered
more open-minded yes you're listen but
they don't have challenging their
orthodoxy so all of a sudden you get
this it's just so well documented you
get this this what sort of like
collective be
I've mine but the iron is the opposite
of inclusion which of their big Fritos
it's the opposite of inclusion of course
yeah but not even on campuses a lot of
times right and so I've been a race to
the bottom intellectually they're not I
talk to them they're not yeah they're
not well they're not widely read they're
specifically read so do you think it's a
deep pat a deep need to be like fit in
and be wanted and be like it's also it's
also when you study having as you yes
but there's also a really weird thing
about being a human being when you study
just one thing biology when you study
just one thing sociology when you study
just one thing oppression when you save
just one thing victimhood you're gonna
see every with you if that's what you
study you only see it through that lens
right right you're a professor or you're
an academia you don't I'm telling you I
talk to them you don't have to contend
with the real world the way we do yeah
not to make a profit it's very real had
to figure out a way to haters do all of
us are very in tune with with what's
going on out there because we mix with
them drink with them we perform for them
we know what they like here that all
over so so but when you're an academic
you don't have to you don't have to run
your own business you don't to make a
payroll you don't have to [ __ ]
actually listen to you have students who
are 17 18 19 20 there in front of you
you have your colleagues who are all
reading the same books as write write
that that's why it lets like with the
Trump stuff and Kenny win again it's
like you haven't oh yeah people laugh
I just people in Houston in the world
yeah you get out the bubble of New York
in LA oh yeah and you getting the
Portland's and you get in the Iowas in
Ohio's Columbus and flow it's like oh
you know he definitely has a chance I'm
telling you it's generating and and the
world those people aren't you know like
online in social media and LA in your
eyes real tight right don't get all your
jokes right everything I know you know
to jump
Campbell is a dave chappelle thing 17
but the critic I haven't even brought to
me we all gave it a hundred percent the
critics are terrified themselves of
going why cuz they have [ __ ] in their
clubs or they don't want to be out there
flaws now you've got journalists from
the places like BuzzFeed if you want to
call them journalists etc who get money
you make money
wiggity say it clear but also but in
anyone who writes a review I'm not gonna
share this common we have nothing in
common if Mark if you came in there like
hey man I went around reviewing specials
the other day and leaving negative
comments like oh you can't be in there
dude yeah yeah be weird we have nothing
to talk about right it's saying god
right I can be friends but even yeah
critics used to be really good critics
used now critics are activists now via
Weiss runs a thing saying you can
definitely skip David Dave Chappelle
sticks and stones that's so we have you
yeah [ __ ] you you and they're all afraid
that they don't have ideas so they just
have outrage and an offense being
offended is not an argument both so but
they don't have they don't have ideas to
match they they're terrified to put
their ideas against these like
Chappelle's ideas pill burrs ideas they
don't matter fight him by their own yeah
so exactly so with all they have all
they have is a way to publicly shame you
cancel you and shame you they're not
there they're too afraid to put their
ideas up against my eyes everybody's a
critic
everyone has their voice now yeah
whether you're critic I'm a podcast with
your critic from your social media
platform these people think they garner
some sort of attention or it gives them
oh I look look what I did man but it
must eat them alive that guys like us
are just like we're on the Internet
we're doing a pot we got our own thing
going you can't stop me sorry I saw
these no matter what you do it but
that's it somebody sent a clip a clip of
these two morons who were it's just so
typical these guys we've never done a
sport and they have a podcast and
they're going bad including on al
Madrigal didn't even know how magical
was God magical is our [ __ ] monkey house
like you're in pain and these two poor
guys these poor guys they just live on
sort of a way of criticizing people like
rogue and stuff but they were it was I
was just like oh dude you guys gotta get
laid
get out there and do something do
something yeah and it's so much easier
to sit out here and go these guys so
right and they hate this [ __ ] alt so
much but they're gonna make Trump win
you're making your your flame in the
fire man you don't even realize it
because you hate it so much and you
won't shut up
it's making it worse it's the same thing
we're putting people are pushing female
and different there put you're shoving
in yeah yeah yeah no no no I don't want
that okay well I want equality of
opportunity and I want it not equality
don't force out equality of outcome are
you good enough are you good enough I
want to comment on a hierarchy of
competence a hierarchy of merit yeah if
you're better than me you make more
money there are plenty of women I can
calculus off of but Lauren they make a
lot more money than I do
and they deserve it right for however
they did it they got more they got more
people interested in them it's just I'm
a liberal douche myself but I'm slam I
scared my own side that's not a good
sign they're terrifying
yeah that's well mainly because
corporations listen to them and you can
get fired yeah I guess I mean [ __ ]
Google and and all these big companies
what's the last company were just
talking about where you [ __ ] up and
they'll they'll fire you everybody can
like you know these these no answer bush
yeah and I know all of them yeah good
rant everybody good edition chin the one
gross one yeah yeah gross gross is the
best this guy's that roulette hunk he's
like me and Brian had a baby
yeah charged with attacking rib so this
girl right here hit biting that's his
girlfriend and this drawer here's his
wife so his girlfriend was upset with
him for some reason like piece yeah well
they're dating so I guess yeah I put in
so she ended up biting his lip mmm and
it was so like an argument yeah it's a
sexual talking whatever and she got
upset with him for some reason how to
I'm sure maybe he was hooking up with
another girl yeah and then uh that's
just that was his lip
that's quite a herpe holy dude I don't
get the biting lit like don't I hate all
that slip off off yeah she tried I'm
sorry what's this girl she's an actress
he's an actress too the actor they act
on the same soap opera and they also did
like Lifetime movies and stuff like that
by the way imagine of a guy pulled today
pulled it off he's got a little Bubba
Gump action but he's alright those
eyeballs though they've dreamy they take
the attention away from the eyes are
nice you bite somebody's lip that's
[ __ ] up yeah it happened to her do we
know criminal charge alright good good
rotten el [ __ ] can't be my I mean that
she shouldn't be walking around the
streets she's a menace dangerous yeah
not cool man especially gonna ruin that
Adonis come on
but if she's hot let her go yeah I mean
sure what the [ __ ] I mean she's a
good-looking she's crazy huh yes women
can be I love women can be very viable
yeah Neil Brenner had that great tweed
leg so bill burr had the great special
man getting a sexually assaulted how
come we're not tracking this woman down
why does anyone care about that he's
like yeah that's a good point
how about the girl that grabbed them
yeah yeah but you know what IIIi think
it does belong to men men matter it's
like my friend
Michaela said I go he has things women a
lot of women seem to hate men now she
goes yeah I know but when men hate women
they kill them it's so great I do think
that I do think that me too belongs to
women I should let story crews in there
as well black guy he can go [ __ ] beat
the guy up what do you do Terry Crews
you got a pass to beat this guy he lost
it he lost me there cuz that guy I know
that that dude who's an Asian is
apparently a great [ __ ] you know yeah I
know I know people he's a great dude and
it's so good I grew up doing that would
do he was trash
- Terry Crews just wanted to be part
Terry Crews it sounds like wanted to be
part of this thoughtful guy before this
year priority is he came out doing a
[ __ ] PR movement on how he's addicted
to porno and he had to tell his wife no
play people know him - yeah he's
straight and you're like you know we can
end on this you touchin nuts
don't get me wrong I wouldn't kick
around my bed for eating crackers Demi
Moore have you seen my no threesomes she
wrote she wrote a new book and she's
like I just want people to know when I
was dating Ashton Kutcher who she was 35
years old or she goes we would have
threesomes I felt like I had to do it to
keep him around like oh well the goes I
liked your book but nobody needs
attention more than that girl but I mean
another person I know and people I know
who work right you know her for many
years I know people that worked with her
for many years and she is she is a hole
that can never be filled
yeah I'd like to draw attention she
wrote a book tell of course she needs to
stay in the limelight of course think
about you went bad on your guy after
that Ashton Kutcher mocked my alcoholism
that's cuz you're 45 daintiness 22 year
old leaves I quit drinking [ __ ] right
drinking it's unhealthy I'm trying to
hold it off so you sign up for you sign
up to date this in massive celebrity
yeah yeah who's younger he wants to have
threesomes and now you're writing a book
yeah with a tell-all [ __ ] he's married
and has kids and the fat guy in the
world and a band and awesome like
intelligence so he's so wealthy from
investing in tech oh yeah yeah me own
dress but yeah monsters and so so you
know a good guy by the way from what I
hear and you go bad on him now [ __ ] off
let's talk about it wait look that's
part of relationship Edie he did want to
go to brunch but he did it you know we
all do things I go to the mall your
[ __ ] kid oh yeah he's gonna hang out
with Bruce Willis's jizz I hate this
[ __ ] culture I want to
get out of here and you didn't have to
kick it with Bruce all the time remember
and show them as a family ah
dashing could you want to take part in
family dance not okay let's move
somewhere like Boise Idaho let's go hang
out Astin Aspen Ashley Ashley I can't
Astin you calm Ashton well either way
that's married that's it mark we love
you day hey man you in my face I mean
our show's canceled now believe me you
blame it all on me you dress exactly how
a New York comic I thought would dress
oh is that right the two of t sponsored
my balamani and New Balance okay I love
New Balance it's all I wear really yeah
for comfort comfort so and I'm a square
honky you know what am i doing I can't
pull a square he's got a you know a
[ __ ] shoe you got a special needs you
have a lunchbox with those no no those
would have gotten Jack than 10 seconds
yeah like - dude where are you gonna be
at [ __ ] you have the Comedy Store belly
room ones line this weekend Sacramento
it's a great club great room great
[ __ ] of it the town's a little boring
but yeah you had a little dicey yeah
it's actually better ones less thing you
went it's like two years yeah I got that
yeah the fire hasn't had a good time
hey guys great news I forgot to tell you
don't do your dates because no no before
we do his dates school is airing tonight
I know you guys are waiting school
tonight
yeah sorry ABC yeah that's somebody
shoot buddy all right a paramount in
Oklahoma Matt the Addison improv
Dallas you got that right yeah yeah the
cap city in Austin big roomy I got some
hot ones on the bill here Brewster T
homers graters yeah yeah unfortunately
it's good no I like that cool I get a
little club but it's awesome
ooh you in Portland end of December yeah
great [ __ ] dates coming up I like
clubs dude I like that roosterteeth we
can they get taken off my list they can
get it done they got a link here more
Normand comedy calm that's it and then
you I'm sure it's on your Instagram yeah
and I got a podcast called Tuesdays with
stories where we get up with a Joe list
and we just do basically we did here yes
oh yeah it was a fun one it's filthy I
mean if you thought this was dark we go
way blacker school for you years tonight
tonight 8:30 ah ah yes and we have a new
J was supposed to add this so Tampa this
weekend Friday Saturday at amp improv
come see me I think some things are
still available and then and then
October 24 25 26 I'm at Brea improv so
you [ __ ] this truck through the ice
house in Pasadena breakdown a friend I
[ __ ] up
we added the state I'm doing Brea in a
month from now so well maybe I gift me
and I'm down maybe you come down my
little room haunt area or Brea right no
no no no too far Bubba it's a little far
I'm on it's an hour but Bram prop 10 24
25 and 26 KJ has now died dude yes we're
broken up can't fly cells we'll
reschedule I'm in Denver hump down
tomorrow night Thursday I think is sold
out Saturday early shows sold out 2
shows Friday Late Show Saturday get your
tickets t fat K Dom free shows on when
one night no no okay you guys live in
the dream next week I'm in Pittsburgh
those shows almost sold out Pittsburgh
improv that is October 3rd through the
5th and then October 17th through the
19th I'm in Philly also all those dates
that I posted the UK Ireland Sweden
Stockholm Amsterdam all tickets are
available this
Friday this Friday don't need to do
pretty sale anymore this Friday all the
stickers are available and I'm at the
Wilbur in Boston
get your tickets Deepak a.com mark
you're the best brazen little game real
comic leaf anal juice
this cartoon wrap all right what an app
good app